outro dia conversando com um colega
padre
ele me disse que fez a seguinte
indagação a seus fiéis
olha eu como representante de deus posso
levá los todos agora para o paraíso que
gostaria de ir e todos levantaram a mão
mas em seguida ele fez uma outra
indagação quem quer ir agora e todos a
baixar o irmão a questão da morte
mobiliza uma série de coisas dentro da
gente
e uma delas é o sofrimento não
necessariamente o ato de morrer que é um
ato natural como o ato de nascer e o
sofrimento ele possui pelo menos quatro
dimensões
nós podemos sentir a questão do
sofrimento em primeiro lugar numa
dimensão física ou seja o nosso corpo
em segundo lugar uma dimensão emocional
ou seja as palavras não ditas as
situações nove vidas elas têm um peso
nesse processo final da finitude humana
em terceiro lugar a questão da dimensão
social porque nascemos numa família
nós nascemos num grupo ou seja
vivenciamos dentro de grupos e vamos
formando esses grupos dentro da
sociedade
e há possibilidade de não viver nesse
grupo também pode causar sofrimento e
por último uma quarta dimensão a
dimensão espiritual e não
necessariamente religiosa
o que nós podemos pensar como a dor da
alma nem nesta questão do sofrimento eu
estudo um autor chamado victor frankl
que criou toda uma teoria sobre o
sentido da vida e ele como pessoa e
vivenciou um sofrimento único porque ele
foi sobrevivente de quatro campos de
concentração nazistas incluindo
auschwitz que era um campo de extermínio
esse ano eu tive a possibilidade de
estar na polônia e visitará ao xix como
turista como psicólogo estudioso do
comportamento humano identificar essa
profundidade daquele que conseguiu
sobreviver às atrocidades que ainda hoje
ocorrem em vários lugares do mundo mas
eu vou contar brevemente dois casos
clínicos que eu atendo uma primeira
paciente que teve um diagnóstico de
câncer de mama
e quando ouvimos a palavra câncer
muitas vezes ela fica vinculado a uma
sentença de morte ea questão esse
sofrimento para esta pessoa foi muito
grande até porque ela também é da área
da saúde entendia o que estava
acontecendo e num segundo momento esse
trabalho nós desenvolvemos todo um
caminho para poder lidar aí com muita
ênfase à questão na vida porque a vida é
o nosso bem mais precioso
e ela conseguiu nesse processo além
dessa viva a mudar a sua posição a sua
visão de mundo e isso é importante para
nós mas não necessariamente
nós precisamos compreender através de
uma doença
uma outra paciente sofreu uma desilusão
amorosa
o que também no seu lado mais agudo
havia uma caracterização de sentença de
morte
e aí trabalhamos uma coisa que victor
franquia chama como uma faísca de
sentido ou seja ajudar as pessoas a
aumentar o seu campo de visão para que
possa de fato ter uma outra imagem e
possa viver novas possibilidades na vida
nem também foi frank o que cunhou um
termo muito interessante chamado trilha
de trágica
todos nós em algum momento da nossa vida
vamos experimentar a tríade trágica e
qual é o sofrimento culpa e desculpe a
essa hora dar essa informação para vocês
mas todos nós vamos morrer mas a questão
não está só ficar no aspecto trágico
a questão está em superar essa trilha de
trágica e é isso que eu gostaria de
passar para vocês hoje a superação das
nossas perdas porque em algum momento da
nossa história isto vai acontecer
a superação das nossas falhas porque nós
vamos errar em algum momento da nossa
história
mas gostaria de dar ênfase na questão da
morte
na verdade a idéia da morte pode nos
salvar porque se não houvesse finitude
nós poderíamos provocar e prolongar as
nossas ações e aí essas ações iriam
demorar dias semanas meses anos décadas
para serem realizadas
mas com a ideia da finitude e isto é
importante
pensem na sua finitude porque tira do
momento que nós começamos a pensar que
somos seres finitos
nós vamos poder aí sim realizar criar
ações com sentido mas particularmente
que essas ações possam ser vivenciadas
hoje
muito obrigada